thank you
[Music]
I try to pit pull articles that remind
me of you guys this one I pulled because
of one Nick done yeah none so the Jews
are at it again by the way it smells
like farts in here dude for reals on
which side this guy this guy before the
video starts and it's like it was
rolling he goes I'm Gonna Go Far outside
I did and right when you left I look at
Steve when I go five bucks says he
brings it back in I said you trailed it
you made a Trail of Tears he was outside
for like five seconds dude I farted and
I even dusted my pants off and then I
came in you dusted your pants yeah I
smell like mervins
dude you could withhold we could [__]
deal with this fart that's a good line
you could smell it
it's okay it's not that bad it could
have been worse yeah like walk along the
length of Joe's truck or whatever like
30 seconds the minimum bro [__] guy
goes right outside the door and [__]
keeps his butt against the crack do us a
favor fart into the catalytic converter
dude turn the car engine on and then
fart in the tailpipe Jesus Christ you
just let it backfire yo we got a [__]
air filter now take that outside far
into it far into the air filter air
filter just dies and then we'll just go
although thank you for farting outside
at least trying to yeah thank you
because old Bart you just let them rip
and then he told us the story earlier
about how he put his finger in his butt
and it was like a rotten poop in there
and then you sound like a fossilized
dinosaur and it stays in like a tumor as
long as you [__] it just kind of moves
around right Jeff what were you saying
about the jam oh yeah so San Francisco a
San Francisco bicyclist or cyclist
sounds like Nick's gonna love this
through a tantrum after her ride was
seemingly interrupted by an ambulance
parked in a bike lane good
see that's harmless it doesn't hurt
anybody except for her feelings and that
makes me happy she threw a tantrum she
really was flipping out right so she
people Gotta Die on my watch ambulance
take to her phone all right oh no and
she's like here's an ambulance in the
bike lane there's a business they can
park in they can block the car Lane they
can block the non-existent motorcycle
Park Lane I'm not even half a mile away
from home on a rainy day what the [__]
what the [__] that's what she said I
hope she's I hope she her bike rolls in
some human poop I hope she drowns that
storm that's coming yeah big old storm
this is a big storm coming to Cali huh
yeah I hope it's drowns in it are you
still drowning well there's another
storm
yeah just drive around that thing why
you gotta complain so much God damn yeah
why you gotta take out your your video
camera and start filming they got more
important job than you do you [__]
recreational ladies yeah so guess what
it gets better is she wearing the whole
[__] outfit too she went off she's
wearing oh it gets so Dynamic helmet
with a big ass yeah it gets Mothership
tail and moose knuckles
but that's okay
stuff this run anyway this block yeah
yeah um no so she goes up to the
ambulance and addresses the driver the
paramedic driver what's he saying get
get of the bike lane you're killing us
get out of the bike I'm not kidding
healing us look at that really
interesting choice of words to a
paramedic
dude I swear to God I'm not trolling I'm
not being a second I'm not trolling I'm
not his sidekick take out the [__]
defibrillator and [__] zapper ass
oh my god dude these so that's why dude
I don't have to improv with this one
because bicyclists are such [__] yeah
they are you know this I always count on
them to be the biggest [__] how did it
happen though entitled people on the
road because look I I think I have a
theory when you're riding a bike I
understand it's like it's like a US
versus them thing so for us meaning the
cyclists versus the cars right yeah so
no matter what that's already weird
though you should be like how do I fit
in with these exactly I think that's the
right mentality but I think when you're
riding a bike sometimes you [__]
freak out because you're really close to
cars and you might get hit so you're
just on edge that lizard brain is just
firing right so I think that's the
reason why they lash out but it's stupid
just drive a car just drive a car dude
or if you're gonna ride in a motorcycle
if you're if you're afraid to get hit by
other cars you need to find a way better
place where you stay on the [__]
sidewalk then yeah but even then they
can't even do that yo this happened to
me at a bike park dude I [__] wiped
out and then I wiped out so [__] hard
and you're not supposed to be you know
obviously in the lane so I'm getting up
moving my bike and his dumb ass [__]
passes Me by and goes you're not
supposed to stop no [__] [__] oh well
let me control how I wipe out you dumb
[__] I'm so sorry I bet she's saying
that as she's zipping past you she's
zooming past she's she's not stopping
she's zooming past me and she's like oh
you're not supposed to stop and it's
like well duh you think I want to
[__] be in the middle of the bike
lane like I [__] wiped out I just
picked up my bike what do you think I'm
doing just [__] walking around
pushing my bike on a bike lane she does
[__] idiot dude sometimes when I'm
driving and there's like uh I'm in the
car with my wife and there's some
cyclists this happened the other day it
was like on a Sunday and it was two
cyclists were blocking this road they're
driving in the middle of the [__]
road and it's like a really wide Road
right but it's single Lane so I can't go
around I don't like do I go around them
what do I do and they're just [__]
Cruising dude they're taking their
[__] sweet time and I made a joke to
my wife and I was like sometimes I just
wish I could have like a long stick and
just throw it right in front of them and
they [__] shoot over the top and me
imagining that was so like cathartic for
me
and I was like oh man this is probably
my way to battle them without having to
say anything just a picture the art of
fighting without fighting exactly or
just a little love tap yeah you know
what we need to install it
give me strength oh my God I hate I hate
to install like a flagpole that comes
out with a button when you see a
bicyclist and it goes and it goes into
their [__] tire yeah yeah
especially with it being jerks a video
that almost made me come
there's a bus driving big bus driving
there's a lady who like opens her car
door as a bicyclist goes by the
bicyclist gets flung underneath the bus
oh my God but he doesn't die so I didn't
come
jeez he actually gets out from
underneath it like in time because the
the guy the driver stopped in time a
bicyclist would never have stopped by
the way
just saying they would put out their
phones
[__] [__] dude the funniest when
those types of things happen to the
cyclists who are filming themselves with
a 360 cam on a stick yeah
oh my God and they just eat [__] yeah
they fly oh I can't stand those guys man
because they're just such [__]
[__] if they weren't so
entitlements if they weren't so [__]
rude it wouldn't be a problem if they
didn't have that I own this road
mentality it was more like how do we
share it together yeah it's because I
ride a moped and I know it's hard to see
yeah because I'm in a little and it's
slow as [__] right and I know I'm
causing [__] traffic but I'm riding
extremely defensively yeah because I'm
not riding around like you see me I'm
riding around like hey you see me right
all right cool like they're not gonna
crash into me right cool and then like I
just get the [__] away from major places
that are dangerous yeah that's that's
the thing though to be fair they're
motorcyclists are sort of the same way
sometimes
yeah sort of a little different but they
at least they at least get the privilege
especially in California of like you
know riding in between yeah so they can
still like one accelerate quickly even
if they like get in front of you and
you're annoyed they can [__] Zoom
yeah versus like they're in front of you
and you're like oh maybe until the next
[__] stoplight to hopefully pass them
the cool thing is that most of them just
kind of will keep going even if they run
into something like even if I it happens
to me I just keep going whatever that
guy messed up he almost hit me cool keep
going but bicyclists will stop and like
give you a whole like lecture it's like
but that's the thing with motorcyclists
right like if you just give them a
little love if they're like on your ass
and you just move over a little bit and
let them pass yeah they bro they show up
they show love yeah they [__] dip out
and it's all good but for cyclists I
think it's the defensive driving you
were supposed to do that it's like
you're supposed to look out for me but
then they're in the middle of the
[__] bike lane or they're like
hugging the lane where it's like in your
car you don't know how close you are to
them so they're like [__] you I think
anybody who's like on like little
[__] two-wheeler thing like that that
has no engine like you gotta [__]
realize that even in California somebody
might pull out a gun and just shoot you
yeah you know what I mean you can't be
[__] going against machines
this video is a [__] oh this one yeah
exactly this happened in this one
oh my what the [__] dude me and Anthony
are kind of simpatico right now it's
pretty perfect setup that was wild yeah
dude and he's recording himself doing it
yeah I need to upload it this type is
dumb dude but that's why right now as I
drive I just try I've been really trying
just just to not give any reactions to
anything like because I know like yeah
people are crazy
it's so tough and then I think I've been
getting really good at getting better at
it but I just I just give no reactions I
don't like to start confrontation if I'm
not willing to finish confrontation so
like I mean Nick is probably the one
that can actually finish confrontation
enough there's a guns in my face or a
knife or yeah well if you're in a
[__] motorized vehicle and they're on
a two-wheeler bike like you could deal
with the car drive
so I learned this watching Steven Seagal
Lawman here hold it hold on yeah
you shot yourself well
he made me pull the trigger
that's how Steven Seagal is teaching law
enforcement [__] made me laugh so
[__] hard I couldn't breathe dude
it's so good he just yeah he just
Maneuvers them and then they're all like
whoa it's kind of cool oh yeah it's like
[__] oh yeah and he's like see how I'm
doing this it's so easy and [__] and
then like everyone's like dude you're
just some fat guy dude yeah you're a fat
guy that means six six is he really sick
so he's like six five
it's gonna be a lot of weight right 250
bro for sure 250. dude I think it might
even be three oh yeah he's three three
so he's like three twenty five six six
eight you're that big like come on
that's pretty because think about
Undertaker dude that guy's like 330
pounds is he but he's like six [__]
seven but he wears a lot black all the
time so it's real slimming yeah oh yeah
he's like in shape or you can [__]
move around your car and he always
starts off laying down with the lights
off
[Music]